[Music]
maile you're her favorite designer any
chance you get to design and plan her
wedding I weigh in as well I'm asking
Megan ever now and this is the cutest
ways ever I'm obsessed with it
Miley Cyrus's mom Tish and sister brandi
are going toe-to-toe on Bravo's upcoming
series cyrus vs. cyrus a show focused on
their passion for interior design but
that begs the question will the momager
and the 29 year old singer take their
design talents a step further and help
Miley plan her wedding something about
it is as you know whether I would have
done a show or not I would have always
been working on her house over wet or
whatever it may be for all my kids you
know I definitely am in there and my
kids are everything to me you know so no
matter what they do I'm there billy-ray
he did an Instagram post that everyone
took his being like a wedding announcer
you guys surprised to all the reaction
from me yeah first of all somebody you
know asked me text me or something like
did Molly get married I'm like huh I
know baby I'm always the last man I was
you know and then I looked at the
picture and I'm like Brandi was I was
feeling that hot like worried that right
crazy-eyed molly was getting married it
would it be without that in that dress
fabulous wedding dress that's like
frilly top she is wearing a photo and I
just loved that he said you know I'm
happy you're happy and I guess people
ran with that man I mean he's like that
and you know with our kids you know when
you see your kids happy it does it does
make you happy
yeah so I um yeah that was a crazy thing
let me ask you this um we all know that
when we get a roommate or we move in
with a significant other you have to
compromise a little on your style we all
have to slightly do this so if you to
design a place for Miley Liam what would
it look like what would be in there the
only thing is is there's best artists
and I kind of love the same thing they
do but I feel like we shouldn't say too
much because on the show that'll try
everything like a whole makeover
Navy Navy
[Music]
you